all right tori
yeah or you're from chicago right
um i was born there yeah
let's let's just recap your story we i
did an interview with you uh probably a
year and a half ago but let's just kind
of do a quick recap
your childhood describe your childhood
for me
um
my mother was a drug addict
my father left when i was six
and it was just me and my sister
and my mom and then got married five
more times
by the time i was i would say 12.
so six marriages
yes
um i was molested by my stepbrother
and he used to beat me up all the time
um
and my mom and my my stepfather was
drunk so much and high on pills all the
time that
they were oblivious to what was going on
around him how old were you
i was 11.
and he was a senior in high school
that's horrible
i'm sorry
and i was pregnant at 16
and
and the guy that i was dating was um
25
and
so i was told i had to get married
um i kind of wish my mom would have told
me to get an abortion because maybe then
i wouldn't become
something else other than a drug addict
i turned into a heroin addict just like
my mother
um i was a stripper
um to support my kids
um
so after i lost that baby i am
got pregnant again and i had a little
girl
and
i gave her up for adoption when she was
two
because
he was abusive and he
made me um i went out to arkansas he
swore and that he had a job
and when i moved out there he had no job
and it was snowing and i had a new baby
and even made me sleep with people so we
would have a place to stay
so i gave up my little girl because i
was so afraid that he was gonna hurt her
that i um
i
would rather give her up than have her
go through
the
abuse that i went through
and
at that time i was
probably 17.
um
after i gave her up i got pregnant again
and i had a little boy
and he was born august the 14th and he
died november the 9th of crib death
and that is when my addiction took
uh
i i
i went into this
i want to die
and i tried so hard
to kill myself and it just when
it wouldn't um
it wouldn't work
and uh
and then i got married again
to another
[ __ ]
who um
cheated on me with girls that were
14 and 13. and
he was um
the reason why i had so many kids
because he was raping me
if i didn't give it to him he was going
to take it
so i kept getting pregnant i tried so
hard to
stop him from touching me but he
wouldn't leave me alone
and nobody believed me anybody thought i
was lying
now here i am
i lost my kids
and i have nothing
nothing just so far except for i was
going out again i'm a prostitute
is this your lowest point right now
is this your lowest point right now
my lowest point yeah
do you ever talk to your kids
no they don't want to talk to me
they hate me
they're embarrassed
i don't blame them
i wish i could change everything
what would you
change have changed about your life if
you i mean you were molested at a young
age
that wasn't your control i would change
getting pregnant so young
i would change
my father
i don't know
i would
i would want him to be in my life i
don't know why they divorced
i was really young i don't even really
remember much of him i don't remember
really what he looks like
other than just pictures of him
i um
i don't remember nothing about him
nothing about my family
i had no contact with my grandparents
which would be his mother and father
i have no grandparents i have no aunts
or uncles
i had no childhood
i had to grow up really fast
so
i would change
going back to school and becoming
somebody
i wish i could do what i wish i wish i
could go back and start over
now i just want to die
i think about suicide all the time
i think about
how everybody would be better off if i
was gone
and i tried to commit suicide
a couple of times
because i get so depressed
i get too messed up
because i'm just so [ __ ] up
what is your drug today
um i'm a heroin addict and i use
fentanyl
um i used to smoke crack
and i used to do methamphetamine
but i quit using uh methamphetamine and
crack and now i just use heroin to
settle
where do you stay now
i don't have a place to stay and sleep
in a tent
you're just on the streets
yeah
and i'm scared
by myself
i worry about getting raped or killed
all the time here down here it's
dangerous
los angeles is very dangerous that's
your girl for sure
skid row for sure it's good bro yeah
definitely for sure i don't know if this
is los angeles i mean yes technically
we're in los angeles but this is another
world here yeah it's a much different
place than anywhere else this
skin row is
is horrible for women especially
yeah i've seen a lot of murderers and a
lot of people killed
yeah just
the way women are treated is
oh yeah we're treated like
we're treating like [ __ ] here
all of us are considered
hoes or
you know even if you weren't a hoe
they they would call you a hoe and being
white and being down here is just as
much dangerous
for being a woman than anything
it's a horrible existence for any human
it is
it is i don't like being down here
i wish i could go somewhere else do you
think you're
even capable of accepting something
better like if somebody was to sweep you
off your feet and give you a home and
all that your addiction kind of would
keep you in this um
environment i don't think so i don't
believe
that um
i'm believing in fairytale love
i don't believe someone would want me
ever
so no i don't think
i don't think i would be able to really
accept it i i would think debate
what what
was in it for them
you know like
uh they're just doing it
because they want something yeah your
ability to trust someone is
yeah it's gone right
yeah yeah i've seen that a lot once
you've been in this
kind of lifestyle for long enough you
just
start to believe that no one's
and it's hard because
when you're pro when you prostitute you
know you might get somebody that really
really likes you and wants to take care
of you
you can't make a
half-life out of a hooker
you just can't
it doesn't work that way
too much damage has been done
too much too much psychological damage
has been done yeah a lot of damage has
been done
um
this is too much damage
i'm
i'm too broken to be fixed
i think
and
i don't i don't think i can be fixed
i don't think nobody would want me when
they want me for
no i've even tried just as sometimes i
try some experiments i've tried
to give somebody like you
everything they need
and they can't accept it
i think it's like you can't if somebody
can't accept it they're
they're afraid to
accept it because once they accept it
they're gonna wait for that other shoe
to drop
you know it's just too good to be true
that whole it's too good to be true why
does he like me so much
and then they wait
for the other two to drop or we sabotage
yes
sabotage sabotage is what i've seen
yeah they they can't believe that this
is for real good so they create a
problem
they create the rejection yeah
they do something that just
forces yeah fall apart yes we do we do
i do
you think you'll be down here the rest
of your life
i hope not but probably
i don't know
um
i've tried to apply for housing
and uh
it's just too much
too much
crap
it's just too much [ __ ] to go
through
um
they want too much from you
um
um they want me to go through uh
counseling and
and therapy and stuff and at first i was
doing it
but they would they couldn't keep a
therapist one therapist long enough
i have trust issues
and i have a problem with opening up to
people and so
they've got this therapist
and she only lasted six months
and after she
left i had there was another therapist
and so now i have to start all over
again
and it got to the point where
i didn't want to keep going through that
having to to redo everything and
to trust somebody again because i have
really big trust issues
especially with women
i have huge trust issues
so
why women more than men i would think
after what you've been through here on
the street men would be
i know and i think it's because
my friends in that kind of or who has
slept with my husband so that's
why i have trust issues it's oh yeah i'm
your friend while they're screwing your
old man behind your back thing
that's why i have trust issues
yeah
i think that's why it is
and i do have trust issues for men too
sure of course you do
it's a lot more to me
they seem to like that's to be expected
you know i love you why they're they're
doing this and this and this you know so
yeah i have trust issues and i don't
think i can ever trust a man
i i don't think i can
i think even if he was doing good even
if he was saying he loved me
i would sabotage it
because it's too good to be true
my mother and i um we don't get along
she's still alive
um my real father i was told passed away
from cancer
my mother
she's not even my mother the person that
gave birth to me whatever
told me not to call her anymore that i'm
dead to her
and uh
i guess
for a long time
i would call her and i you know in my
even in my addiction i would call her
and tell her
you know mom i'm doing really good i
want to go to school and i want to do
you know i want to become a
vet technician and my mom would find
something
to knock it down
always
and i think the reason why i kept trying
to call her was i was looking for that
at a girl
and it was never there
um i was never really close i guess with
my mom
um
a lot of my
addiction i started using when i was
really young
i was an alcoholic
by seven i was drinking
vodka and
um
orange juice and beer
and
brandy and whatever i could drink
my mom would have cocktail parties
and we would go and empty the glasses
we would sneak out there
and we would empty the glasses we would
drink them until we were so wasted
and
i smoked marijuana i started smoking
marijuana
um i was babysitting and
when i started babysitting at nine
somebody the kid that i was babysitting
before their father was molesting me
um i went home i told my mother
and my mother said
that it was my fault
if i wasn't dressing like i was dressing
then he wouldn't have done what he was
doing
um so i would run away a lot
my mom was very abusive
and she used to slap me around a lot and
she dragged me up
fly the stairs
by my hair
and she tried to turn me over her
her knee to spank me at 11
and i punched her
and she took me to juvenile hall and put
me in juvenile hall for hitting her
and i told her that it would be better
staying here in juvenile halls and to be
with that with her because i called her
a [ __ ]
i cut up my mom's furniture
and her house
i took a butcher knife to my mom's
furniture
and i cut up all her couch her pillows
the cushions on her on her couch i
destroyed all her
dishes
i stabbed knife marks
in the door of her bedroom
i cut up her bed her pillows
and her sheets and all her clothes
and
i guess i was just acting out because
she was
an alcoholic an alcoholic and
she
would drink so much
that
she does not remember things
and
we'd ask if we can go somewhere and she
would say yes and then we come home and
and we'd get our our ass beat with
anything that she can grab
whether it be a cutting board a wooden
spoon
a metal spatula
whatever she could throw at us
you know
she would throw at us
and uh
so
you know i guess that was my way of
acting out was to
to cut up her her stuff
you're angry at
her behavior
uh bad behavior i was
i was something
but you were you were angry
yeah i i was
i was angry and there was no way of
talking to her i couldn't find a way to
talk to her
because she was so drunk all the time
you know she was never sober
do you feel like where you're at your
behavior today is kind of some
result of that from behavior in your mom
when you were a kid
i think yeah i think it has a lot to do
with my mom i am my mom's daughter
and she danced when i was really little
um i have one memory and
me and my sister were sleeping in the
car
and i had woke up
and my little sister then
she was
two years younger than me
so i was probably
five or six
and i went in to the
bar and my mom was on stage nude
and i grew up to be the same thing i was
a stripper just like her i was an
alcoholic in an addict just like her
so i am my mother's daughter
my behavior is just like hers
tori thank you so much for
coming in and talking with me again
i really appreciate it
thank you very much
i'm sorry
it's never gonna change
hmm
you